(screaming)
(upbeat electronic music)
- My name is Joshua, I'm in sixth grade,
and I'm an expert on speed stacking.
- We are cup stacking.
- Never heard of it.
- It's like, get cups,
and then you stack them.
- They're going to be
learning the three six three.
It's where you have six cups in the middle
and you have three cups on the side
and then you have to stack
three then six then three.
- When I'm timed, I go.
And I'll be done in less
than five seconds, bam.
- So what do you do?
- I do a thing called speed stacking.
I learned from my sister
when she was in fourth grade.
She brought home a stack of cups
and then she taught me how to do it.
Cup stacking means to me,
like, just a fun thing to do,
and then I got good at it.
- Do you think you could
teach us in 50 minutes?
- Yeah, I think you guys
could do pretty good
if you get it right.
- He's legit, guys.
(laughing)
- Take one cup and the
other cup, and yeah.
Exactly like that and then for the six,
you want to take three cups in one hand.
- Three then two.
- Then two cups in the
other hand, no that's three.
- This is challenging.
- Yeah, and then the other cup.
Down.
And when you're ready, you
go back to the beginning
and take the top cup and the other cup.
- Shoot.
- Whoa.
- And then you bounce
that down, yeah good.
Great, awesome, 17.
- 17, awesome, I can't believe it.
- This is fun, it's really fun.
It's getting a little frustrating
but I really at least want to get the 20
or you know, maybe even
15 or 14, so let's go.
And by the way, dude, thank
you, you're being very patient
with someone who's pretty bad at this.
- Let's do this.
- Tyra will do good because
she's like crazy and fast.
- Buddy, Ivan, he's
going to do really good.
- Kailee, I think she's very mature
so I think she'll take
it pretty seriously.
- I don't know about Toby,
it's going to be a question.
- I'm as competitive as Ned, so I'm going
to be great at this, yeah.
- [Ned] That's right.
- Competitiveness, baby.
- Cup stacking, let's do this.
- Bom bom bom.
- My whole body is buzzing right now.
- Me too.
- I really want to take this one home.
- [Voiceover] Three, two, one, go.
(upbeat electronic music)
- 15.
- 19.
- Okay.
(upbeat electronic music)
- 13, whoa (cheering).
- And the winner is Tyra.
- Yay.
- And the winner is Kailee.
- Good game, buddy.
- Good game.
- You did a good job.
- This is going to be
like an epic showdown,
but it's going to be
like very nerve wracking
and stuff like that.
- We never know, we just
have to believe in ourself,
right, we can do this Kailee.
- [Voiceover] Three, two, one, go.
(upbeat electronic music)
- And the winner is Tyra.
- Yay.
(clapping and cheering)
- See, you just believe.
- Good job.
- I learned a new skill today,
like a new hobby that I like to do.
- When I was alone with Josh,
I thought I wouldn't make it
because I had a lot of mistakes,
but then for the competition,
I just knew I could do it, so.
- I didn't think I was going
to make it to the finals finals
but if you just believe you could achieve.
- And Josh, again you were amazing, bro.
Thank you for coming.
- Thank you for coming Josh.
- Thank you for teaching us a new skill.
- [Voiceover] You guys
want to see me try it?
- Yeah, go.
- Sudden.
- Where's my other cup, no.
- [Voiceover] Finals fail.